about a NuNormal with NUCALA.
>> LAWLESSNESS IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
AND IT STARTS AT THE TOP
POSITION OF THE COUNTRY.
IT NEEDS TO STOP AND BIDEN NEEDS
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
LAWLESSNESS HE HIMSELF HAS
CAUSED.
BIDEN WANTS OPEN BORDERS.
HIS PARTY WANTS OPEN BORDERS.
IT’S BEEN RECKLESS, DANGEROUS,
AND DEADLY.
NOW NOT JUST WITH THE FENTANYL
DRUGS BUT WITH PEOPLE KILLED IN
THIS REGION.
>> Ainsley: TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT BLASTING BIDEN’S BORDER
POLICIES AS HE CALLS ON
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY TO HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE.
FLORIDA’S ATTORNEY GENERAL
ASHLEY MOODY WAS AT THAT
BRIEFING WITH GOVERNOR ABBOTT
AND SHE JOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU, THANKS,
AINSLEY.
>> Ainsley: TELL US ABOUT THE
MEETING?
WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE AWAY?
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT THOSE OF US THAT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO SOMETHING TO HOLD
THIS ADMINISTRATION IN LINE WITH
FEDERAL LAW GET TOGETHER,
DISCUSS HOW WE CAN DO THAT AND
REALLY SEE THE IMPACTS OF RIGHT
HERE WHERE IT’S HAPPENING IN
PERSON, YOU KNOW, MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN DOWN HERE MULTIPLE
TIMES.
I WAS HERE WITH GOVERNOR
DESANTIS OVER THE SUMMER.
WE STARTED SEEING RECORD FOLKS
POURING OVER THE BORDER.
WE WERE FEELING THE EFFECTS IN
FLORIDA WITH DRUG OVERDOSE
DEATHS BE CRIME, AND WE FELT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO BE HERE.
NOTE THAT THE PRESIDENT STILL
HASN’T BEEN HERE.
IT’S SO IMPORTANT THAT THOSE OF
YOU WAS THAT CAN GET TOGETHER
AND PUSH BACK WE GET HERE
STRATEGIZE AND TALK TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PLAN.
>> Steve: YOU MENTIONED DRUGS.
HE SAID YESTERDAY THAT MEETING,
THE LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH OF
FELLOW AMERICANS, AGES 18 TO 45
IS FENTANYL.
HE SAID NOT CANCER, NOT CAR
WRECKS, AND NOT COVID.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS, ASHLEY.
THE AMOUNT SEIZED LAST YEAR,
10,586 POUNDS OF FENTANYL.
THAT IS UP 132% FROM THE YEAR
BEFORE.
WHAT KINDS OF STORIES ARE YOU
HEARING FROM YOUR CONSTITUENTS
IN FLORIDA OR YOUR FRIENDS IN
FLORIDA ABOUT THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, I WILL GO ON
UNRELATED EVENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF FLORIDA AND I WILL HAVE
PARENTS TELLING ME ABOUT LOSING
A SON THAT WAS A STAR ATHLETE
AND TOOK A PILL THAT HAD
FENTANYL AND DIED OR FOLKS OF
YOUNG CHILDREN THAT TAKE PILLS
NOT KNOWING KNOWING IT HAS FENTA
IT.
ONE PILL CAN KILL.
WE ARE HAVING TO LAUNCH
CAMPAIGNS TO GET THIS MESSAGE
OUT.
BUT SO MUCH OF THIS IS
PREVENTABLE.
YOU KNOW, AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR, WE SAW REDICK RERIDICU
ACTS.
CANCELING THOSE WHO WENT AFTER
SEXUAL PREDATORS OR OFFENDERS.
TELLING OUR SHERIFF TO RELEASE
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITIES THOSE
THAT HAD BEEN TRAFFICKERS OR
BURGLARS EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
HERE ILLEGALLY RELEASE THEM BACK
INTO THECOMMUNITIES WHEN WE KNOW
WILL REOFF
WHAT WE ONCE THOUGHT WAS JUST
THEM FAILING TO FOLLOW LAW.
FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES THAT OBAMA
DID IT, TRUMP IT D. IT, YOU
DEPORT KNOWS HERE ILLEGALLY
COMMITTING CRIMES BUT NOW, NOW
THEY ARE GOING A STEP BEYOND,
THEY ARE BUILDING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND PROGRAMS TOTALLY OUTSIDE THE
LAW TO FACILITATE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION IT MUST BE STOPPED.
WE WILL PUSH BACK.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR SHINING A
LIGHT ON THIS.
>> Ainsley: NOW WE KNOW ABOUT
THESE SECRET FLIGHTS.
ONE WENT TO YOUR STATE,
JACKSONVILLE THAT WE KNOW OF.